remember something Bernardo that you
said look at this this we think of as
solid we feel it there's solidity to it
yet we look at it through a microscope
and we say yeah the atoms are far apart
this this solidity is an illusion that's
if you take materialism as primary what
if you take your conscious experience no
no this is solid this actually is solid
there's something real about that
there's something real about this table
there's something real about me
inhabiting this world I can go through
this process where I feel like oh that's
all an illusion but then there's this
quote about TS Elliott that the point of
the journey is come back where you
started and know the place for the first
time I feel like that I'm slowly
starting where I feel the reality of
this more I feel it but then there's a
negging part of me that's like yeah
you're tricking yourself GT you're
tricking
yourself we let our theories hijack the
reality of our experiences and that's a
tragedy